from nbcnews.com and and I'd love to
hear your your Recollections on the
event your coverage Catholics and other
religious protesters gather at Dodger
Stadium on Pride night the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence whose members dress
in drag as nuns were honored for their
work and this is of course the NBC right
version so we'll tell the story we'll
listen to NBC's story and then we'll
tell the story of what we actually saw
with stop anti-catholic hate and God
will not be mocked signs protesters
surrounded the main entrance to Dodger
Stadium on Friday hours before the
sisters of Perpetual Indulgence were
where to receive an award on LGBT Pride
all right I'm gonna have to stop right
there because the very first sentence of
this is not true it wasn't hours before
the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence uh
were to receive the award we swarmed the
main entrance while they were receiving
the award and we were out there with
rosaries we were out there with uh
thousands of people the LA Times
actually came out and admitted that it
was 2000 people so if the LA Times
admitted it was 2 000 people it had to
have been at least four thousand five
thousand uh six or seven I couldn't even
lost count of how many helicopters news
Shoppers were up in the air uh do we had
drones flying all over the place and and
it was peaceful it was prayerful we had
a bishop uh reading a prayer of exorcism
Sheamus you'd appreciate Bishop
Strickland not not only not only gave a
prayer of exorcism but a prayer for
perimeter protection from demons wow and
this was the only time it's funny
because I thought about it weren't they
already performing at the stadium I know
right so inside while all this is going
on there's there's the March that takes
place takes up space blocks the gate the
inside at that time is completely empty
during the ceremony you could go in and
Savannah Hernandez did actually go in to
get the footage showing in empty Stadium
while they received the award and of
course the fact Checkers are coming out
saying well hold on a second people
actually went to the game and they were
able to see the Dodgers play and they
played a game against the Giant and Los
Angeles entire series by the way to the
San Francisco Giants from Northern
California
um like the worst loss in 125 years wow
and that's awesome and then these are
like the you know the hated Rivals right
the Dodgers and the Giants and they
going to lose this in in a massive
fashion but the ceremony itself was
completely drowned out by the protesters
so peaceful
and I you know what I didn't see though
was and look I've been or Posto's been
to hundreds of events with antifa uh got
into it interactions face to face say
what you will
I didn't see any of them there I didn't
see any of this I saw a couple of
counter protesters
well because I was telling you a couple
of revcoms but they never crossed the
street and I kept wondering why aren't
they Crossing sure why they come across
and then someone I was there with goes
well did they not cross the street or
did they not cross the perimeter and
it's like
yo
Bishop Strickland so look look I mean
just from from my recollection my
perspective it was incredible it was
incredible to see I mean Sheamus of
course was being lazy didn't want to
come out yeah because that's exactly
what I didn't want to say lazy didn't
want to support the faith didn't want to
show up when it mattered you know he was
willing to be here Tim you weren't there
to be Catholicism oh right I mean poso
was there and uh and then some of us you
know some of us showed up when it
mattered like our good friend here so
tell us what was it what was it like for
you on the ground what were your
Recollections
um was was it what the media says was it
an anti-lgbt hate Fest
um no so um I think it was a beautiful
beautiful site because it was the first
time their Protestants and Catholics
were not at each other's neck about
who's right about what so it was kind of
nice to just be alongside God-fearing
people people who believe in the Gospel
of Jesus Christ just going around and
finally standing up to what I thought
you know was was a satanic agenda that
was happening at the Dodger Stadium with
these sisters of Perpetual Indulgence
who openly mock uh you know and
blaspheme our Christ but you know what's
so interesting to me is Christians will
will and this is why again sometimes
like 90 95 of Christians conservatives
sit at home all they do is type online
don't know what the heck they're talking
about never been involved in anything to
any capacity
um and they just like to just you know
oh this is stupid a protest what's the
point of a protest what's a what's the
point of a prayer walk what is that
going to do people that never show up to
the community and of course just useless
I'm sorry I'm kind of bashing on them
right now but um uh it was it was it was
really good to see it was a great site
thousands of uh you know uh Jack
besolovic was there he's not here
tonight but but it was a great sight to
see him and I was just kind of wondering
there's a lot of like other influencers
that go hard in the paint for for Christ
and just weren't nowhere to be nowhere
to be but
um we were there man you know and there
was a like revolutionary Communists that
were there
um you know talking about there is no
Jesus there's no this
um but it was it was really good to see
just uh this this public display of of
Christians coming out uniting uh saying
the prayers marching as men it's the
most men I've ever seen activated
usually Conservative Christian men are
at home drinking their Bud Light so it
was actually nice to kind of see them
come out into the street and actually uh
act out the things that they professed
one of the things that I was a little
bit upset about was that the Archdiocese
of how does that work I know you guys
have like a structure within the
Catholic system it's like the
Archdiocese I don't know if that's like
a like a little small government of of
Catholic Branch inside but so so each I
mean the the basic breakdown is is you
know a diet parish is a diocese so one
church is usually a parish that's one
Community basically a neighborhood then
the Archdiocese they're typically based
around Metro areas okay so you'd see the
Los Angeles archdiocese I was born and
raised in the Philadelphia archdiocese
Tim Prime was born and raised in the
Chicago archdiocese me too um your
Chicago Choice as well yeah yeah and
then so and then that would sort of uh
raise up then there's a a Catholic
conference for the Bishops of the United
States there's a number of cardi B so
there's a number of cardinals there's
what five Cardinals in the U.S right now
uh I believe outside my head could be
totally wrong and but it's not a lot
it's not a lot of Cardinals and then all
of the Cardinals around the world
eventually uh choose the pope whenever
there's it's time comes time to choose a
new pope yeah and so that's that's the
base I mean there's way more to it than
that but that's the very basic structure
so basically the Archdiocese of Los
Angeles came out they were supposed to
be leading this I think that thousands
more people would have come out had they
actually endorsed it but days before the
prayer walk they basically backtracked
and said hey you know what um where
we're actually not going to endorse any
protests we're actually wow we've
decided that we're just going to have
open dialogue with the Dodgers and any
parties involved meaning the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence
um but you know I it's weird because I
have Christians telling me well yeah
that was a good call because what's the
point of a protest who cares like we are
meant to be persecuted as Christians the
thing I care about is that these same
Christians had it been that they were
mocking Jewish rabbis it was if it was
Jewish rabbis that they were making fun
of and the ADL put out a statement we
strongly condemn these sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence that dress up as
rabbis and are you know mocking the
Jewish faith this is not Christians
would have stumbled over each other as
the Marco Rubio's and and other you know
uh uh people that uh are always like
standing up for Israel and its allies
they would have been like oh we stand
with the Jewish people and this is not
this is we we which by the way there was
a rabbi actually at the event there was
a rabbi Michael Barclay from Los Angeles
was at the LA area right so they spoke
at the event right before Jack presovic
right yeah I remember that and so to me
it just it's mind-blowing to me when
Christians justify that it's okay to
persecute Christians in Christian
America country founded on Christianity
and that but if it was it Islam it'd be
islamophobia and if it were Rabbi it's
anti-Semitism but it's perfectly fine
when it's done to Christians and so to
me I'm like okay well you can't have it
both ways either we can make fun of the
Jewish people and the Jewish religion
and we can make fun of Islamic Islam
people and Muslims or it's it can't be
it can't be that you know like you gotta
have it I'm all for it we're sure we're
going to be persecuted yeah we're going
to be blasting this and that but what I
don't understand is why you have
Christian legislators including just
recently Governor Ron DeSantis went out
to Israel and signed an anti-semitic
bill out there in Israel and promising
you know Israel like Hey we're going to
make sure that there's no anti-Semitism
in Florida they've extradited three
people in three different states I
believe two Florida under that new new
anti-Semitism bill but it's like but why
can't we do that for Christians this is
a Christian country we have Christian
majority legislators why isn't the
protection so my argument against
Christians and again I don't understand
why we do this but Jack posto was there
well you know we were there we showed up
we understand the importance of showing
up for our religion for our people
um and and just standing in solidarity
because to me it's just not right well
and and to to your question about the
legislation that there are obviously uh
concerns about uh what constitutes
protected speech under the First
Amendment as opposed to what what is
considered hate speech or hate crime
laws hate speech laws
um which you know we're not going to get
into right here but that's obviously a
major concern but also and Sheamus I
want to ask you about this as well
because this call by the Archdiocese
yeah for dialogue that's a communist
tactic that's a hegelian tactic this is
the exact same thing and I know the
thesis the antithesis
classic exactly so you have you have the
thesis you have the antithesis and then
and after dialogue it ends up breaking
down into the synthesis you have a new
idea now I'm not going to sit here and
claim I know what the motivations of the
Archdiocese were in making this decision
but what I can tell you is that I
personally believe it was a very bad
decision I think that this is something
they should have called for so that
people in the area would know that this
protest was something that the church
was sanctioning and there's a lot of
conversation in the Catholic church
today among Bishops and Priests who
consider themselves to be more moderate
about trying to unite with and have
dialogue with Protestants so it's
interesting that at this protest that so
many Protestants were attending it was
decided that the church couldn't and
even shouldn't endorse it of course I
think the reason is pretty clear if I
were to guess the motivations I would
say it was simply a case of them being
afraid and them not wanting to say
anything that would upset the alphabet
people the lgbtqiaap lobby or anyone
else who's pushing for sexual perversion
in this country because as you know
the the dominant prevailing State
religion that's been emerging is one
which celebrates sexual perversion and
unfortunately uh as is to be expected
just given human history the history of
the church in in the way human beings
behave there are people in the church
who would like to be accepted by those
who would persecute them because they
don't want to face the ostracism that
would come along with persecution and so
they're either willing to bend the knee
or even if they don't bend the knee
they're willing to tell other Christians
to stand down to tell the faithful to
stand down to tell Catholics to stand
down and not adequately combat the evil
as it must be but so then so then if
there's if there are these these at
least at least two thousand according to
the LA Times 2 000 which means to me
there must have been at least double
that because the LA times has to have
been two thousand I saw it on Daily Mail
as well because Daily Mail originally
said that there would be that there were
hundreds of protesters right hit refresh
and then it's immediately said top of
and it stayed up all weekend thousands
of protesters so Sheamus what is this
split inside the church then because is
there a split between uh you know the
phrase of the laity the laity of the
church or members of the laity into the
hierarchy of the magisterium at least in
the U.S
um not to go to Uber into the Catholic
weeds here but it just seems like
there's a split between the trads and
the moderates yeah well the the trads
the the modernists the moderates there's
a lot of different ways of looking at
this and to be honest I don't consider
this to be in any way shape or form
unprecedented if you look at church
history once the Roman persecution ends
a great deal of Catholic history ends up
being the story of good holy faithful
lay people being saddled with a corrupt
hierarchy that has some good people in
it but who do not follow the lord as
they should and do not lead their flocks
as they should and we also see this in
the the Holy Scripture I believe as a
Catholic that at the Last Supper when
Christ established holy orders that
Judas was ordained so this is one of our
first examples of a priest and a bishop
and he betrayed Christ so we should
expect to see that there will be judases
in the church today and as we've seen
throughout church history it has been
full of them historically so when people
are unwilling to stand up for Christ and
when Bishops and clerics are unwilling
to which many of them are lay people
fortunately historically have risen to
the occasion even though it has not been
all of them many of them have and it's
it's what we should expect to see not
only among the hierarchy but among the
laity right because many seek to enter
and few do how many people truly take
their faith seriously how many people
are truly trying to get closer to Christ
and enter the Kingdom of Heaven surely
it's a minority and I believe that the
scriptures make that clear I'll also add
that it is not something disobedient or
offensive or even subversive for a
Catholic to say that there are many in
the hierarchy who are bad the venerable
Archbishop Fulton Sheen said that he
believed that the laity were going to
save the church and it's because again
we've seen it repeatedly with the the
hierarchy abdicating it is why it was
once said that the road to hell is paved
with the bones of priests and the skulls
of Bishops or the lampposts that light
the way thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time